foreign
[Music]
to shoot these stunts for Mission
Impossible with Tom there are no limits
so we become a little bit more
adventurous every time
Tom's doing a sport very few people on
this planet do it's called speed flying
it's a very beautiful and delicate sport
but it also is one of the most dangerous
sports in the world while it may look
similar speed flying is not skydiving
skydiving is fairly predictable speed
flying is incredibly unpredictable
it's a very small canopy racing down the
mountains just feet off the ground these
sort of Crosswinds could put Tom in
peril
we're gonna do spirals
and we're Landing in an incredibly high
speed over 80 kilometers an hour
we've been training for a few years now
and we're always looking for what's the
most dynamic way to shoot this
foreign
coming up with the stunt is only one of
the technical challenges the other is
putting a camera in a place that you can
see where Tom is operating the speedway
you can't get close to this with a
helicopter or a drone so we had to
develop a gimbal system flying along
with Tom who had cameras hanging off of
both sides being operated in a
helicopter what's going to work is
here's you here's me this is what we
need
that's one of the things they're doing
practical action we are at the mercy of
weather
too dangerous
the wind's dropping down it's only going
to get better let's go let's go let's go
I'm ready
confirming you have pictures good
Thomas airport Thomas airborne
flying very close to rocks looks quite
beautiful
behind the scenes we were all in
absolute Terror Landing Tom had to be
flying towards the camera vehicle that
meant that Tom had to hit the exact mark
or it can end it disaster
[Music]
it is truly a one of a kind Adventure
Our Lives
are the sum of our choices
[Music]
we cannot escape the past
this mission of yours
must you
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing war is coming
long time friend
you've no idea the power represents
it knows your story
and How It Ends
listen to me
the world's coming after you
his fate is written
shall we write yours too if anything
happens there's no place that I won't go
to kill you that is
all right
[Applause]
Ethan what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that
[Music]
foreign